there there are crowds out there they're
trying to figure out what's going to
happen in the draft and we've talked
about so many quarterbacks leading up to
the draft kyler murray dwayne haskins
drew lock but there's been this daniel
jones thing that has been percolating
it's been percolating and chris you've
pushed back against it but despite your
best efforts it continues to build and
grow and charles robinson of yahoo
reported last week that one team has
daniel jones as the top quarterback on
their board and gil brandt who's going
to have a hall of fame this year and
he's in the cowboys ring of honor he is
comparing daniel jones to
peyton freaking manning of all people
talk about high expectations for a guy
entering the nfl we talked about this an
hour ago we have more real estate at
this point to really flesh it out but
chris when you hear this about daniel
jones based upon what you've seen based
upon what you've studied what are your
thoughts on daniel jones and this daniel
jones hype bubble that continues to grow
no it does it continues to grow
certainly uh uh first thing i would say
is let's pump the brakes on the peyton
manning conversation again you know
gilbran i respect the hell out of him
and i know he's seen a lot of good
players and all that but man peyton
manning was gonna be the number one pick
in the draft for two years in a row he
could have came out as junior year he
decided to stay he ended up being it
after his senior year when they lost the
orange bowl to nebraska peyton manning a
big man was a very good athlete and
again you know peyton manning this gets
disrespected a little bit about his game
a much better athlete than people
realize and when you go back and watch
peyton manning highlights watch him
scramble and throw on the run you know
look at some of the throws he made in
the super bowl against the saints on the
run and some of the things like that you
know uh okay and then you know as far as
the rest of his game the arm and all of
that yeah peyton manning didn't have an
aaron rodgers arm or brett favre or john
elway arm but when peyton manning was in
his prime of his career it was one of
the five best arms in football i mean
especially deep down the field seems
down the middle comebacks outside daniel
jones is a very good player don't get me
wrong i don't look at him as a first
round talent but as i've said a few
times over the last few weeks i know
teams have fallen in love with you know
his brain the way he processes
information the amount of workload he'll
be able to handle as far as an offense
and all that i get that where i worry
about daniel jones is just pure physical
ability you know there was just times
and games where if defenses took away
some of the david cutcliffe slam dunk
completions i didn't think daniel jones
was a good enough thrower athlete to
make some plays on his own to move the
offense and to me that's what a first
round quarterback is that's where i push
back a little bit but it only takes one
team and to me when i hear gilbrant do
this i said this in the first hour this
to me is like old world nfl and i really
feel like the giants and some of the
media here in the new york area for the
last week is trying to set up
the
daniel jones is going to be our number
six pick and they're trying to get the
fans to digest it right now and gil
brandt i think ernia corsi who used to
be the gm who drafted eli manning who
has the cut you know a relationship with
david cutcliffe and then i also think
okay he hired david gettleman uh of
course he he was part of that the giants
hired a corsi to to find the gm and
gettlemen so to me when i connect the
dots there it just seems like that's
what's happening and i think right now i
would say the giants are going to pick
daniel jones at number six that's what
it looks like to me
and here's what gil brandt said on
sirius xm nfl radio last week about
daniel jones i love dan jones i have to
say this carefully when you watch him
and you go back 20 years and watch
peyton manning you are watching the same
guy he's athletic he doesn't have a
rocket for an arm but neither did peyton
he's very smart and you've got dave
gettleman who is really feeling a lot of
pressure here really feeling a lot of
heat getting a lot of criticism and i
could see how he would be susceptible to
the influences of an ernia corsi someone
he can lean on in tough times when he is
in the center of this storm in new york
when he's being accused of not having a
plan of not knowing what he's doing
gettleman was pushing his own resume
recently to push back against the
critics but you know that this is a safe
pick and one of the things gettleman
said recently
is that he wants someone with the mental
makeup to survive in new york chris
that's just another that's another
little piece i guess in this puzzle
right it's not about the physical
abilities about having the brain power
it's about having the personality it's
about being able to deal with new york
but you still have to have the minimum
physical ability or it's all going to
fall apart hey you've got a great
attitude for being you know 1 in 15
every year because you're not getting it
done and i think that's a concern that
can come to fruition if you really can't
play at the level he needs to well yes
okay and there's two things here first
off this is the one thing that i want to
say to all the public and people out
there like i feel like i've heard this a
little lately too and this is like greer
and jones you know and we talk about
will greer but daniel jones specifically
here i've had some people go you know
his arm was a little bit better during
the workout than i thought it was on
film and this is what i've even told my
friends you got to be wary of people
like that you know daniel jones real arm
will grier's real arm is what i saw in
week seven week eight of college
football you know right now they're
fresh as hell they're not practicing
every day so you get to see a guy who's
had a week off from throwing and then he
comes out and throws 70 balls and you go
oh wow that popped out of his hand okay
great you know but is it gonna pop out
of his hand that way in week nine after
it's the ten thousand football he's
thrown this season because those are the
things i worry about and daniel jones to
me is a high effort thrower from that
standpoint now to your point about what
new york is i think you're very hon
there's some truth to that no doubt
about it and daniel jones again i don't
like being the guy that talks negative
about young 20 year old something men
because i know he's good and he's
working hard and i hope he proves me
wrong and he can call me an ass one day
i hope he does i really do but to the to
the thing you talked about you know the
i'll call you an ass today
but the there is some eli manning phil
sims you know let's think of kerry
collins one thing i think of all those
guys it was just like this always and
they could handle the new york the highs
and lows of the new york media and i do
think in new york that is something that
you have to take into account maybe more
than other cities
and and you know you start invoking the
manning name when you're starting
quarterback is in aging manning that
there's just it's
it's almost too obvious exactly yes i i
just
again it's you know i i like to do this
i connect the dots or connecting the tea
leaves okay when i look at all that no
you had it right the first time you
don't connect i wanted to deliberately
mess it up but when i take it all
together yes just the way it seems like
it's playing out in the media things i
hear
to me it just seems like it's all a
propaganda thing to sell new york on
daniel jones because the giants are
getting ready to take him at number six
and a minimum a trial balloon to see how
people do react exactly right how
whether whether people shout it down or
whether people embrace it and i think
they are still stung a year and a half
after the fact from the reaction to the
benching of eli manning that they were
caught flat-footed when they walked into
that that they had no idea that people
were going to be as upset as they were
and i think when something like that
happens it shakes you to your core when
it comes to
your self-awareness like do we just have
this wrong do we not understand our fan
base do we not properly relate to how
they feel and i think that before they
would make a move like this this is part
of what they would do i'm not saying
that this means they're doing it yeah
but this is what we should expect if
they are that it's pointing that way the
trial balloon the fan base reaction do
they seem okay with it we've put it out
there for a while now the smoke signals
are there how are they reacting to it
and ultimately you don't want them to
lose their minds if daniel jones is the
guy you get we talked earlier about this
before we take a break let's revisit the
idea of the psychology of when you would
take daniel jones when you have pick
number six and pick number 17 because
you could in theory take somebody other
than daniel jones or any other
quarterback at six
and hope that he's there at number 17
and you get the best of both worlds and
you know obviously you run the risk
getting leapfrogged by somebody else
who's fallen in love with daniel jones
but that would be one way for the giants
to proceed you think maybe the safer
thing is just go ahead and take him at
six if he's your guy i just it would
scare me to wait to 17 and hope that
that guy's there now you did mention
okay maybe if you're at 17 and the guy
you want is still on the board at 10 12
whatever it may be then you make maybe
another move you trade 17 and maybe your
second round pick to move up a few spots
whatever it may be to get that guy um
but yes for me again i don't agree with
daniel jones at number six but if the
giants really are sold that this is
their guy yeah i wouldn't flirt with
danger you know what what are we gonna
do okay
okay you know pass them up and then
nobody's there at 17 and all of a sudden
you're might be having this whole same
discussion next year about what the hell
they're going to do at quarterback and
they might have to make a move in the
first round and move up more whatever it
is if you love your guy take it to
number six move on it's quarterback
hopefully you've done your homework and
you're sold on you know what the results
have shown and and i think it should be
as simple as that
you know i hate to agree with you it's
more fun when i don't but if he is your
guy if you love him and you think he's
going to be your guy for the next 15
years then whether you're at 6 16 1
wherever you get him and maybe you even
can say i don't think you consider trade
god do you consider trading up i mean
that's the other problem here that
enough people start talking about daniel
jones and he gets enough lift that
somebody jumps you at six not at 17 but
it's six yeah i don't know that they
have to worry about that i don't think
so but that's something that could
happen too you're right i don't think so
either i'm with you i think everything
you said mike that it's just all about
this was gauging fan interest here's
this is what we're thinking they're
trying to set up and i think at six i
don't think they're gonna have to worry
about anybody trading up in front of
them to get daniel jones i would be
shocked if that was the case
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports